نحب تركيا كثيرا
لا يستحق هذا الشعب الحب نحن
نحب هذا الشعب
اما هؤلاء الذين هم في قنديل جبل قنديل
من التنظيم الارهابي
وامتداداته لن يحبوا هذا البلد وهذا
المشهد
هو مشهد المحبين وحسب الرقم الرسمي قد
تجمعتم انتم وعددكم 320 الف
عدا الطرق
من المطار الى اليوم كانت الطرق مزدحمه
بكم
ما شاء الله
[تصفيق]
جمهور اتفاق المحجوب انكم
امال تحالف الجمهور ولم تتركوا تحالف
الجمهور وحيدا في هذه المسيره حيث سرنا
سويا
ليل نهارا
وانكم انتم
او اكلتم الينا هذه المهمه مره اخرى وان
شاء الله سنستمر في بناء مئويه تركيا معا
هل انتم جاهزون
ايها الشعب العزيز
وايها المواطنون الذين يتابعوننا من خلال
الشاشات التلفاز
سكان انقره
[تصفيق]
اخوتي انني
احييكم
بمشاعره في اعماق قلبي وبكل محبه واحترام
ولله الحمد قد مرت الجوله الثانيه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه دون حدوث ايه مشكله
وحسب النتائج غير الرسميه حتى الان
فان الشعب قد
كلفني
باداء رئاسه الجمهوريه
لولايه اخرى
لخمس سنوات كي ين
فصل وانا اتقدم بجزيل الشكر الى كل شخص من
ابناء هذا الشعب الذي كلفني بهذه المهمه
[تصفيق]
مهما كان
اختياره وانتخابه في الجوله الاولى
والجوله الثانيه
فان كل من ذهب الى صناديق الاقتراع
واثبت قوه الديمقراطيه في تركيا يستحق كل
الشكر والتقدير بغض النظر عن اختياره
وانتخابه
كما انه لا يفوتني الا ان اشكر
الموظفين والمسؤولين
والمسؤولين ايضا عن الاحزاب وقوات الامن
والمراقبين ايضا وكلهم يستحقون التحيه
قرار
الشعب قد صوت لصالح ميعويه تركيا في هذه
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تركيا
وان هذا الشعب كذلك
قد اختاره ان يكون معظم
النواب في البرلمان
من تحالف الجمهور
وفي هذه الجوله الثانيه
كان خيار الشعب واضحا في اختيار من هو
سيتولى السلطه
التنفيذيه وخيار وقرار الشعب على الراس
والعين
سادجه ولكن
لسنا نحن
من فاز بل الفائز هو تركيا
مثلا تبتسم لذيذه مله
هو الشعب نفسه بجميع اطيافه
والفائز الديمقراطيه
لو تتذكرون اننا قلنا في جميع المناسبات
وذكرنا بانه في حال فوزنا لن يخسر احد في
بلدنا
ان من سيخسر هو من يدون سيناريوهات سيئه
لبلدنا
ومن يؤيد المنظمات الارهابيه
وكذلك من يحاول ان يقوم بنصب اموال الشعب
الان
لم يخسر احد
وقد فاز
كافه الشعب التركي
البالغ 58 مليون نسمه ونحن بمقتضى
المسؤوليه التي
نتحملها بناء على اراده الشعب لسنا
منزعجين
وغاضبين من احد وقد تركنا الخلافات
والنزاعات السياسيه التي
تجلت خلال الحملات الانتخابيه جانبا
ونعتبر الوقت هو الوقت التوحدي
والتضامن وهذه ليست مجرد شعارات وانما
كلماتصر عن صميم قلبنا ونحن نعلم باننا
نمثل هذا الوطن
بجميعه
اعدادنا انا لست متخصصا في الحساب مثل من
يدعي
الاخر
ولكن هذا المدعي بانه متخصص في الحساب
يبدو انه اخطا في حسابه
[تصفيق]
كان عدد النواب لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
146 نائبا
وفي عام 2023
وصل عدد النواب الى 169 ترون هناك زياده
ولكن هناك نواب مستاجرين
[موسيقى]
اربعون نائب مستاجر
حتى الاحزاب التي
حصلت على واحد بالمئه من مجموع الاصوات
حصلوا على اربعين نائبا مستاجرا اذا العدد
الصافي
129 ايهما اكبر
129 لا تستطيع ان تقول يعني انه هناك
تراجع كبير في عدد النواب من 146 الى
129 ولا يمكن السير معه في الطريق اعتقد
[موسيقى]
تقولون لهذا الشعب وانتم
بالظهر الى المنظمات الارهابيه
وتقولون هيا ولكن هذا الشعب لم ينخدع لذلك
[تصفيق]
اخوتي واخواتي
يقول اذا كنتم تريدون اطلاق سراح
صلاح الدين ان
تعيدوني ماذا قال هذا الشعب الحبيب
انا شعبي يعلم ويدرك جيدا
اللي بين
هذا الشخص
الارهابي هو كان متسببا في مقتل 51
مواطنا من مواطنيه في مدينه ديار بكر
وفي تركيا التي
تسودها العداله والحق والحقوق لا تستطيع
ان تاتي الى سده الحكم ثم تقوم باطلاق
سراحه على ما تشاء وانه مستحيل ان يتحقق
هذا الشيء خلال حكمنا
وفي حكمنا
العداله اساس الملك ولن
يتغير هذا المبدا
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الراحل
عدنان مندرس
حين قال كفى
والقول للشعب
ذاك الوقت من الخمسينات الى اليوم وقعت
انقلابات من اجل اضعاف قوه الشعب وكانت
المذكرات تصدر
باذالك وقد تمت تشكيل حكومات ائتلافيه
لهذا السبب
وان
خلافاتنا التي تعتبر ثراء لنا قد تم
تحويلها الى
خلافات وتنوعنا الذي كنا ثراء قد تم
تحويله الى خلافات وقد تمت محاولات
لعرقلتي قوتنا ايضا
وفي جميع مناطق تركيا الشماليه والجنوبيه
والغربيه ايضا نجد ان هي قد تم ايضا
محاوله تقسيمها لهذا السبب
وكذلك ان هؤلاء الذين دائما كانوا يحاولون
ان يغرقون
ويلبسوننا لباس
المجانين وكانوا يعلمون بانه اذا ما تم
ترك هذا الشعب سياتي يوم هذا الشعب سيثبت
جداره تهوى وقد حان هذا الوقت وانتم
موجودون لذلك واليوم
انتم قد اثبتم ايضا
بانه اليوم
سنصل الى اعلى مستوى لما كان الراحل عدنا
من درس من اجل تكريس الديمقراطيه ايضا
وكذلك نحن اليوم نعلم بانه ايضا
جميع هؤلاء الراحلين من اربكان وتركيش
وجميع هؤلاء الذين
قد افنوا حياتهم من اجل هذا الولد واليوم
هو يوم بلوغ غايتهم واهدافهم ايضا ونحن
على مر 21 سنه بدانا نتحدث عن مئويه تركيا
وهذا حان الوقت
لنطلق لكم هذه البشاره باشاره مئويه تركيا
وهذا ما حققناه معكم
اليوم
هو
النصري
والشكر
واليوم تعلوا اصوات الشكر الى السماء خاصه
مع اخوتنا من الدول الصديقه والشقيقه التي
كانت تتضامن معنا وبعد الاعلان عن النتائج
لم تسكت
هواتفنا ولم يسكت رنين هاتفنا من دول
الخليج الى اوروبا وكذلك من في اوروبا
انجلترا وغيرها
وراينا ان قاده ورؤساء الدول يتصلون بنا
للتهاني ايضا
وان تركيا رغم القيود ورغم العراقيل ورغم
الدسائس
فان تركيا قد تصدت بذلك وكان بهدف الوصول
الى هذا اليوم وقد اصدرت المجلات
الالمانيه والفرنسيه والبريطانيه نعم
مناوئه لاردوهان اليس كذلك الم تنشر في
صفحاتها الاولى ايضا رسوما واخبارا مسيئه
الى اردوغان ان هؤلاء قد خسروا اليوم ايضا
وقد رايتم التحالفات التي تشكلت على مر
اشهر ماضيه ورايتم من تضامن مع من ومن وقف
الى جانب من وكيف كان هناك تعاون بين
المنظمات الارهابيه
والتعاون ايضا مع المنظمات الارهابيه ومع
المنحرفين
واصحاب الافكار المنحرفه والحمد لله لم
ينجحوا ولم يفلحوا ولن يفلحوا بعد ذلك
ايضا لان هذا الشعب يعلم ان
هو في واقع الامر
سليم صحيح
بالاصل وكذلك ان هذا الشعب قد اثبت
نضجه ورشته في جميع الانتخابات وفي جميع
التحديات ايضا ان هذا الشعب التركي
لا يمكن ان يقع في خطا وكلما يفكر بانه
يمكن
خداع هذا الشعب
سيصاب بخيبه امل مرارا وتكرارا وايضا نجد
ان هذه الوقفه الان بهذا المشهد
تكشف عن عزه هذا الشعب ايضا وان شاء الله
نحن باذن الله تعالى نستطيع ان نتغلب على
جميع التحديات والمشاكل ما من مشكله الى
ونحن قادرون على حالها وتجاوزها وانا احمد
الله عز وجل
واشكره
لانه جعلني واحدا من ابناء هذا الشعب
اخوتي
وشعبي العزيز
بما ان الانتخابات قد انتهت وما علينا الا
ان نسخر جهودنا كامله
للانتاج ولتقديم الخدمات
ولخدمه هذا الشعب ايضا
وما علينا الا ان نقوم باستكمال تضميد
جروح
الزلزال وربط
الناس بالحياه وهذا ما سنجعله ضمن
اولوياتنا ايضا
ونحن
سنستمر بالتركيز والاهتمام بالمناطق التي
تضررت من الزلزال وما علينا الا ان نبذل
جهودا من اجل ايضا
الحد عن تداعيات اقتصاديه
ناجمه عن التضخم المالي وان حل هذه
المشاكل ليس بصعب
وانني استطعت ان
اخفض في على ما كنت رئيسا
للوزراء حيث تقلصت نسبه الفوائد الى اربعه
فاصل تسعه بالمئه
وايضا نسبه التضخم الى سته بالمئه وهذا ما
فعلناه هؤلاء هل فعلوا شيئا لم يفعلوه
منحن من يستطيع ان يفعل في نهايه الامر
نعم الان
الفوائد الربويه قد الى ثمانيه فاصل خمسه
بالمئه وتاكدوا انكم سترون كيف ان التضخم
المالي سيتراجع ايضا قريبا هؤلاء لا
يستطيعون ايضا ان يتسابقوا معنا هؤلاء كل
املهم هو ان يجلسوا ويتربعوا امام صندوق
النقد الدولي
وايها الاخوه الاعزاء تعرفون كيف اننا ان
فصلنا عن
منتدى دافوس
الان كان هذا بابا جان بجانب
ونحن نتحدث والتقينا انذاك برئيس الصندوق
النقد الدولي
انذاك تركيا مدينه للصندوق ب
23.5 مليار دولار وانا سالته قلت هل ان
تركيا تدفع
ايضا جميع الاقساط لدينها قال نعم انا
استلم قلت اذا لا يمكن ان تجرؤ على التدخل
في الشؤون التركيه وما عليك الا ان تستلم
اقصى دينك فقط وماذا فعلنا استمرنا بدفع
الاقساط حيث دفعنا القسط الاخير في عام
2013 ثم بعد ذلك قطعنا صلتنا بصندوق النقد
الدولي هكذا هذا ما فعل ولكن هذا الحزب
حزب الشعب الجمهوري ماذا يقول يقول ان
نذهب ونقترض من صندوق النقد الدولي يقول
ما هذا شانكم لن نفعل منذ ذاك الوقت الى
اليوم قد مر عقد من الزمن ولم
نقترض من صندوق النقد الدولي وكان
احتياطي انذاك البنك الدولي
مليار دولار وهؤلاء ماذا يقولون سنذهب الى
انجلترا وستدفع لنا 300 مليار دولار هؤلاء
لن يدفعوا لك شيء لان هؤلاء السماسره اصلا
والسمسار يعرف السمسار يعرف سيقرض من
ولماذا اي نتيجه من يعلق الامال على
السماسره نتيجتهم قد ظهرت في هذه الجوله
الثانيه ونحن نسير في طريقنا بخطن ثابته
وسنستمر في ذلك ايه الاخوه الاعزاء الامن
والاستقرار
امراني مهما انا اتحدث عن هذين المفهومين
مع اخوتي ايضا قلت لهم علينا ان نمضي قدما
بالتركيز على الامن والاستقرار وسنبني
الاداره القويه لبلتنا على هاتين
القاعدتين المهمتين
وكذلك
علينا ان نتحول الى اقتصاد انتاجي قوي
ونحن من خلال زياده قواتنا في القطاع
الصناعي والانتاجي سنتحول وسنحقق قفزه
جديده
ستبهر الجميع والان في البحر الابيض في
البحر الاسود قد اكتشفنا الغاز الطبيعي
اليس كذلك وقد
قمنا بتوزيع الغاز الطبيعي مجانا على
شعبنا لمده شهر كامل مدار سنه كامله
ايضا نوزع على شعبنا هذا الغاز الطبيعي
ايضا
نعم وقن وعلنا عن ذلك وهذا ما نفعله نحن
والان قد اكتشفنا النفط في جبل غبار وهذا
لم ينكشف وحده بل بالبحث والتنقيب وفي
الماضي
ماذا كان هناك ارهابيون الذين هم على صله
كمال رئيس المعرض ولكن
كان يتم الصب الاسمنت على العينات
المستخرجه انذاك ونحن ماذا فعلنا استخرجنا
النفط هناك الان يتم اعاده التنظيم ايضا
القوه قوه توازن مره اخرى في المنطقه وان
ستصل الى المكان التي تستحقها وايضا
سنستمر في مكافحه المنظمات الارهابيه دون
توقف وسنقوم بتفعيل القنوات
السياسيه والديمقراطيه بشكل سليم وسنبذل
جهودا كبيره وباعمال كبيره ونحن ايضا
سنستمر في ابعاد هؤلاء ايضا عن حدودنا
ماذا كان يقول حلفاء باي باي كمال
وكانوا يقولون نحن سنكون مع المنظمات
الارهابيه المتواجده في جنوب تركيا ولم
يكتب وبذلك
وبداوا يتخذون خطوات بتقسم النفط هناك
انظروا قامشلي مثلا
واحده فانهم تحركوا مع قوه التحالف ايضا
وايضا
نحن نعتبر بان العوده الطوعيه للسوريين
الى اراضيهم بشكل امن جزء من السياستنا
البناءه هذه ونحن ايضا نريد ان نستجيب
لتطلعات وطلباتي
شعبنا ايضا
والى حد الان قد تم
عوده العوده الطوعيه ل 600 الف شخص الى
المناطق الامنه التي بنيت في شمال سوريا
والان نحن تعاوننا مع دوله قطر وعبر مشروع
سكني الجديد سنؤمن عوده مليون شخص الى هذه
المناطق الامنه
وبدءا من التعليم الى المواصلات والى
السياحه
والرياضه
في المجالات التي
نحن كن قد حققنا نجاحات سنستمر
بالاستثمارات من اجل زياده سقف نجاحاتنا
ايضا
وكذلك نحن
سنستجيب لتطلعات شبابنا ايضا
وسنطور برامجنا حيالهم دون توقف لا وقفه
وفي قطاع الصحه
استطعنا ان نعزز البنيه التحتيه الصحيه
ومنظومه التامين الصحي وسنقوم بتطويرها
اكثر ايضا سنزيد عدد المدن الاستشفائيه
لدينا وكذلك سنستمر في
استثماراتنا في مجال الطاقه
سنتحول في استثماراتنا الى
استثمارات عالميه من اجل تعزيز مكانتها
والرئيس بوتين
ذكر في رساله التهنئه بان نجعل منطقه
التراكيا
مركزا
للطاقه وسنتخذه هذه
الخطوه وان شاء الله لنجعل منطقه طراقيه
مركزا
للطاقه بالتعاون مع روسيا
ونحن سنزيد ايضا من القيمه التجاريه ومن
قيمه العلامه التجاريه
لصناعتنا عالميا كذلك سنتخذ خطوات مهمه
للتقليل من تكاليف ايضا
زراعيه
وسنقوم بتسهيل ايضا
الامور وكذلك لدى المزارعين
وسنستمر في تحقيق
نجاحاتنا السياحيه ايضا
وسنعز
نظام التامين الصحي حتى لا يبقى اي مواطن
خارج عن هذا التامين حتى لا يشعر بانه
مقصا من ذلك
اخوتي واخواتي وباختصار اننا سنستغل كل
وقت خلال المرحله القادمه من اجل
بوضع وبنائي
نتائج
مهمه وفقا لمشروع مئويه تركيا غدا نحن
سنقوم
بالاحتفال
بذكرى فتحي اسطنبول حيث ان فتح اسطنبول
وهو قد اغلى
عصرا واحدا وفتح عصرا حيث ان هناك حديث
يقول لا تفتحن القسطنطينيه
نعم الامير اميرها ولنعم الجيش ذلك الجيش
وهذا هذه البشاره قد تحققت قبل
570 سنه وغدا
سنقوم
باحياء ذكرى مرور 570 سنه
لنستذكر
ذلك القائد ونستذكر ذلك الجيش المبارك
ايضا
ونعتبركم احفاده
اجدادنا وانا افخر بكم واؤمنوا فيكم
واثقوا فيكم وان شاء الله تعالى
نعتبر
هذه الانتخابات
بوابه دخول الى مئويه تركيا
[موسيقى]
وقلنا
باننا نحن في واقي الامر
امانه لتركيا وامان لكم وانا اشكركم جزيل
الشكر
لتبنيكم وحفاظكم على هذه الامانه وعلى
وفاءكم وعلى
التزامكم وانا اشكركم فردا فردا
كذلك اذكر
هنا شهدائنا في الرحمه والترحم وبكل اجلال
هؤلاء الذين هم
صانوا هذا الوطن
بارواحهم
وكذلك اذكر الشهداء الذين سقطوا في
المحاوله الانقلابيه يوم 15 تموز
وهنا
اريد ان اذكر
واؤكد لكم بان
هذه الرايه التي حملها لنا شهدائنا لن
تسقط على الارض يوما وانتم من اثبتم ذلك
اليوم من خلال هذه الانتخابات واقولوا
دام الشعب التركي ومبارك مئويه تركيا
وايضا مبارك هذا النصر وانا اريد ان استمع
كلمتي بشعر الدعاء للشعر التركي عارفني
نحن اصوات خافته الانسان
لا تحرم الماذن من الاذان يا ربي ادعوا
او لا
تتركهم دون البيوت يا ربي
ان المنارات لا
بدون اناره ولا تجعل السماء بدون ايادي
مرفوعه يا الله
الهمنا القوه
ولا تجعل ميدان الصراع بدونه مصارعين يا
الهي
ومن ينتظر الابطال لا تحرمهم من الابطال
يا الهي علينا ان نعلم كيف نقف ضد الخصم
لا تحرمنا من الروح يا الهي
ولا تحرم غدا
وسنواتنا بدون الصلاه والدعاء
اما مزق وشدد الرعيه او لا تحرمها من
الراعي يا الهي لا تحرمنا من الهواء
والماء
والوطني يا الهي
ولا تجعل هذا الوطن المعجن بالمسلمين بدون
مسلمين يا الهي وانا اذكر واترحم لهذا
الشاعر التركي عارفني
واستودعكم الله ودمتم بامان
[تصفيق]